for the global Jihad is
international everywhere that Muslims
and non-muslims live in the same region
Muslims Mage wage war against
non-muslims and attempt to impose
Islamic law over them we have to stand
together as the people who are
victimized or potentially victimized by
Jihad Warfare our family doesn't have a
grave even people who has a grave on a
cemetery they get J just small piece of
body from mother from father from son
rest of the body it's Ash and blood and
everything on the ground zero this is
the grave this is the bual place and I
don't want to say what all Muslim is
terrorist of course not but people 19
people who kill
3,000 American they was Muslim and we
don't want mask on the ground zero they
can build any place but not Ground Zero
I don't know what to say to jaw a
memory's memory I want America to
remember what you need to hear you want
to hear that there were people that were
so frightened that they jumped out of
buildings and they exploded on impact
you want to hear that they were
dismembered bodies all over the way you
want to hear that we looked at people
that would got it there's things that we
haven't spoken about we couldn't stop
the people from responding the fire
department that day lost
firefighters they were Unstoppable they
poured into that building the p
Authority police 37 police officers
NYPD 23 police officers EMS lost people
civilians were there they helped people
they died helping people America where
are you on this where are you don't you
remember don't you remember what is it
going to take for you to remember
she's de dead
[Music]
[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen let me start by
saying no musk
here no
[Applause]
we
are we are here today because we have
not forgotten all the loved ones that
were lost and those left to carry on and
neither has the world when the forces of
jihad attack New York they attacked the
world and amongst
those lost were people from 55 Nations
people of every religion of every
persuasion no place on Earth on Earth
was more multiethnic and multi- lingual
than New York's proud's towers and this
ladies and gentlemen this is exactly the
reason that they were targeted they
constituted an insult to those who hold
that there can be no peaceful
cooperation among people and Nation
without submission to Sharia to
those indeed to those who wish to impose
the legal system of the Islamic ideology
to the rest of
us but
as we all know as we all know America
New York and Sharia are in
compatible New
York New York stands for freedom for
openness and for tolerance indeed New
York is rooted in Dutch tolerance New
York is tolerant not intolerance suppose
New York were
intolerant suppose it would only allow
people of one persuasion within its
walls then it would not be New York but
it would be like
Mecca
Mecca a City without Freedom whatever
your religion your persuasion or your
gender is in New York you will find a
home but in Mecca if your religion is
not Islam you are not even welcome to
enter the
city ladies and gentlemen may me may we
one day have an American president who
has the courage and wisdom to suggest
that perhaps the anniversary date of
9/11 could be used as a day for the
Muslim world to try and understand the
non-muslim world
as a big mouth on the radio a white
Methodist American citizen may I be so
bold as to speak for a moment for this
non-muslim world I think I can safely
represent This World by reminding all
that this debate has never been about
religious liberty no one has ever
suggested that mosques be banned no one
has ever advocated any serious effort
for a Muslim moratorium no one has never
ever suggested that Muslims aren't free
to Worship in the way they wish to
Worship in fact most of us understand
that this Ground Zero mosque is likely
on solid legal footing no this is not a
legal or technical debate nor is it any
kind of anti-muslim Hysteria this is
simply a belief that family members
whose loved ones were brutally murdered
the ones we heard from today should be
respected when they say that an Islamic
mosque at this site is wildly
inappropriate
uh I think we all also remember the
passengers and crew of United Flight
93 uh who in many respects were the only
opportunity the victims of 911 had to
Counterattack uh they didn't need the
government to tell them what they do
what to do they didn't need politicians
to tell them what to do they didn't need
opinion leaders to tell them what to do
they knew what to do and they did the
right thing there on United flight
93 uh and I think as we remember and
honor the victims and the uh families uh
of the 911 tragedy uh it's with with
that in mind that we have to view uh the
proposal to build the ground zero mosque
it's a very strange Enterprise that says
we want to increase religious tolerance
and understanding uh and if you don't
agree with that we're going to increase
religious and tolerance and
understanding whether you like it or not
uh that's really a very unappealing face
to put on uh the supposed effort behind
the M uh ladies and gentlemen we are at
a Crossroads we are at a watershed
moment in our country's history
history I have a 11-year-old soon to be
11-year-old son and I fear for his
future and let me tell you
why the latest
rationale for having this mosque here
according to Imam
rou is that if he moves it
now he doesn't know what the radical
islamist might do
[Applause]
we don't care we don't care we don't
care we don't care we don't care we
don't care the day that we start
worrying about the actions of terrorists
and that's what they
are over the concerns of our own safety
our own country our own decency we are
finished
with some words from a president that we
know and love his name is Ronald Reagan
and he talked about a
time he talked about a time when America
would have a Rendevous with Destiny it's
happening right here at Ground Zero
we've had one here before we're having
it again it's up to you ladies and
gentlemen it's up to you and you know
that mayor Rudy Giuliani made an
excellent point
recently and he said if this mosque is
really about building bridges and these
folks are about healing then they're
going to hear this message and they're
going to move they're going to move the
right thing and they're going to
move but if they're
Warriors if they're Warriors they're
going to dig in and they're going to
stay well you know what we have Warriors
too
for
[Music]
h
I've listened to the spokespersons with
the mosque state that this mosque
Islamic Cultural
Center would be instrumental in building
a bridge to serve and improve
relationships I've also listened as the
majority of Americans in New York and
the rest of this country have expressed
their
opposition to The Chosen location due to
the reminder of the great suffering we
have incurred at the hands of Islamic
terrorists We Believe to build at Ground
Zero would in fact show Less in the way
of peace and tolerance but more in lack
of respect and a bold Act of
insensitivity although the Constitution
affords this right we do not believe
that this is as much about rights as it
is about honor and
integrity in other words just because
you can do something doesn't mean you
should I want to tell you something
about the American CER for Law and
Justice we have firsthand experience
with Sharia law that's right we have an
office in Israel but the first case we
had handled was for a Palestinian
Christian in Gaza her husband who ran
the only bookstore that sold Bibles in
Gaza City was killed by Hamas in the
street no
justice no court dat and yet this
Imam refuses to call an
organization who killed a pregnant woman
last week in Israel and rushed to claim
responsibility he refuses to call them a
terrorist organization Iman Roth America
rejects you we reject you and we reject
your ground zero
mosque do not ask us do not ask
me the 911 family members to continue to
tolerate to be tolerant of those who
demonstrate selfish and self-serving
behaviors and
attitudes Iman Abdul R is quoted as
saying this week that if we don't do
this right the moving of the mosque
anger will explode in the Muslim World
wellon anger is exploding in America
too he stated he stated that if this
situation is not handled correctly it
could become something very dangerous
indeed does that sound like tolerance to
you it actually it actually sounds more
like a
threat and by the way whenever they tell
you that it's 600 feet from Ground Zero
this is your response
lie that building is Ground Zero that
building was hit and partially destroyed
by the planes that went into those
Towers there were human remains in that
building that building is Ground Zero
why there I ask you why there why such a
deliberately provocative act now
speaking of media bias you may you may
recall that Pamela and I hosted a rally
in June on this spot
and many of you were here and the media
coverage was all about an Arabic
speaking man who was supposedly roughed
up by the crowd and that showed that we
were all racist anti-muslim islamophobic
bigots well he's our next
speaker Joseph nasrala
came from
California to support the this cause and
to stand against this mosque in June and
he is here again today he is a Coptic
Christian human rights activist from
Egypt and the founder of the way TV a
Christian satellite TV station and so
please welcome Joseph nasrala thank you
thank you thank
you God Bless
America God Bless America
wake up
America wake up all the states of
America it's written in the
Quran it written in the Quran that the
war is
deceiving they can lie just to build
this MK here on my dead
body on my dead
body you know why because I escape from
Egypt for a freedom here where I can go
you need me to go to the moon now to
have a a land on the
moon Islam is the big ideology
here they
coming they using tea they using
deceiving they lie for the pastor for
they lie for p Giller and Robert Spencer
they lying lying lying lying I hate
lying you come here for
Freedom I'm sorry to show you my
picture this is one of our dear friends
in
Egypt one of
eight eight of them in the Christmas
night in the name of
Islam they said
allahar and they kill
them in front of the church
3,000 B burned here in the same area
they they need to build the mosque and
can you imagine that but this is an
aerial
photo of ground
zero and some of the men in my unit made
this for me and I carried it next to my
heart inside my Flack jacket when I was
in
Iraq and I'll
no ladies and gentlemen the message here
what's important here is the words on
the top say never
forget never
[Applause]
forget IM Ru refuses to condemn
terrorist because he says that terrorism
I quote is a very complex
question he says and I quote again Imam
that America is an accessory to the
crime that happened on
9/11 in fact Imam said in the most
direct sense I quote him again Osama Bin
Laden is made in the
USA and terrorism will only end if the
West acknowledges the harm it has done
to Muslims ladies and gentlemen this
crazy and idiotic remarks of this
extreme Imam proves that this man should
never play the game he has in mind here
in
Manhattan he is in fact traveling the
world uh at our
expense uh as a uh paid spokesman for
the state department sent around the
world uh to explain our country to other
people not withstanding the radical and
extreme statements that he's made so
even beyond the MOs controversy even if
a new location can be found uh I think
we need to have a serious conversation
about what it is at the state department
that has motivated them to finance uh
the Imam and perhaps others like him
thank you guys I'm I'm happy to see how
many American came it mean we stay
together like a n years ago I
remember everybody stay together it's
wonderful nobody can put us on a KN I
can tell you everybody ask same
question uh how you feel after 9
years I can tell you a secret very
bad every year is bad is more it's worse
because I get older and I feel lonely
and nobody
can bring me back my son I want to ask
Mr Bloomberg because in another way I
have no chance to ask him Mr Bloomberg
tell us please do you sleep well you
don't have a bad dream
nobody talking what we against to build
mask no everybody can build anything
what they want you want to pray God
bless you you want a mask God bless you
but not put mask on the cemetery because
this place
like Rosa mentioned I'm a 911 paramedic
I lost two of my partners that day and
it really saddens me that we even have
to be here
today I listen to the Imam say he didn't
know the pain this was going to inflict
[Applause]
I hear the Imam say he wants to bridge
gaps and bring Muslims and non-muslims
together does that look like it's
[Music]
[Applause]
happening I'll give him the benefit of
the doubt maybe he didn't know then but
he knows
now there should be no doubt in his mind
when 75 plus% of the people say don't do
this when family members who've been
victimized are standing out there and
saying please don't do this so they
answered to anyone's question if this
guy's doing this to be provocative or if
he's doing it to build Bridges well
we're going to find out tomorrow if he
continues with this monstrosity or if he
stops This Disaster now many of the
families as you've heard today whose
loved ones lost their lives at the hands
of Muslim extremists are positively
anguished over the idea of a mosque
being built so close to the spot where
their precious family member took their
last breath today as we memorialize
those who died and remember the family
friends and countrymen left behind we
stand in solidarity with those who
believe that an Islamic cultural center
and mosque in the shadows of where the
Twin Towers once proudly stood is an
appalling lack of sensitivity and
respect in fact it is the height of
disres
respect and a blatant and offensive
assault on the legacy of those who were
slaughtered by extremists who did what
they did in the name of
Allah the people I'll say it again the
people who want this Moss built it is a
symbol of
conquering it is a symbol to the Muslim
world that they conquered and let me
leave you with this someone inform me of
this and take it for what it's worth
when you get home Google the Quran
translation this is called project 51
why go to I know back to go to chapter
51 in the Quran and go to the address 44
to 46 chapter 51: 44 45 and 46 I'll
leave you with that tease and you will
understand why they will never ever move
the sight of this mosque it must be
built here or it's worthless to
them there is no lack of mosques in New
York the contrary dozens of buildings
where Muslims can pray it's not about
the lack of space for prayer it's about
the symbolic meaning and we should not
allow that to happen here
[Applause]
my fellow good and decent and fine and
righteous Americans I want to thank you
from the bottom of my heart for coming
out today and standing here for hours
because you stand for America you you
say yes to freedom and no to the Ground
Zero
mosque thank you it's all
you and so we come to the end of this
and what have we done we have
strengthened our resolve we are never
going to give
up the political Elites are out of touch
with the the will of the people and that
means the political Elites are going to
have to give
way and they will never be a mosque at
Ground
Zero
never thank you very much and God bless
you watch Aly rugs and Jihad watch for
the next rally we will be calling upon
you each one of you as a soldier we need
you now is the time thank you
[Music]